cet acte dramatique survenu ce matin
intervient à peine deux semaines après
le meurtre de samuel paty et et on
l'entend sur cette antenne c'est un
nouveau drame qui réveille à nouveau la
colère est aussi certaine tension donc
vous parlez donc de drames d'émotion de
colère je pense qu'il faut maintenant
rapidement sortir de l'émotion vous vous
rappelez probablement que le l'attentât
de jus janvier 2015 avait été suivie par
de longues semaines ou la totalité ou la
quasi-totalité des acteurs politiques et
médiatiques ne parvenez pas à
s'abstraire de l'émotion le bataclan a
généré exactement le même phénomène avec
en moins
la marche du 11 janvier qui ne s'est pas
reproduite c'est à dire que on a senti
qu'il ya quelque chose qui avaient
cliqué on ne pouvait pas continuer
reproduire encore le schéma des fleurs
et des bougies et de la compassion
advitam eternam
on ne pouvait pas reproduire le schéma
d'une unité de surtout pas de
stigmatisation comme on l'avait fait en
janvier donc entre janvier et septembre
et novembre 2015 on a vu qu'il y avait
déjà quelque chose qui avaient commencé
à basculer
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on aille encore
plus vite c'est à dire que cette
résilience de la population doit être
encore plus grande
il faut comprendre que plus nous passons
de temps nous morfondre et ou à nous
laisser emprisonner par la colère et
l'émotion et moi nous rationalisons
philippe vardon l'a dit il ya deux
minutes
s'il a relayé en cela les propos et les
appels de marine le pen et d'une large
classe partie de la classe politique
c'est à dire qu' il faut faire évoluer
notre législation
en deux mots qu'est ce que ça signifie
ça signifie que les ennemis islamistes
est un petit et demi il faut bien
comprendre ça c'est un nain géopolitique
l'islamisme n'est en réalité pas une
menace pour une puissance telle que la
france si la france est capable de se
doter d'une législation adaptée
aujourd'hui pourquoi nous parlons déjà
cette législation on en a beaucoup parlé
sur notre antenne ces derniers jours on
a le sentiment d'après certains que
finalement tout le
le nécessaire législatives existent déjà
seulement il n'est pas appliquée non
mais c'est faux il faut dire que les
gens parlent malheureusement de ce
qu'ils ne connaissent pas donc si je
peux donner un conseil de lecture vous
allez sur le site du figaro et vous
allez lire l'interview qui a donné j'en
ai richtel à offrir au vox et là vous
allez comprendre comment cet ancien
secrétaire général du conseil
constitutionnel voit la situation et
comment il explique par le menu que à la
fois la constitution française le socle
des droits de l'homme sur lequel est
construite et ensuite les couches de
droite un peu technique mais
supranationale c'est à dire le droit
européen lié à la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme donc l'ensemble du
droit qui favorise qui protègent les
libertés individuelles nous emprisonne
et nous empêchent de répondre c'est pour
cette raison là que nous ne parvenons
pas fermer la mosquée de pantin plus de
six mois c'est pour cette raison là que
nous ne parvenons pas à expulser des
imams qui sont pourtant radicalise et
c'est pour ça que nous parvenons pas à
fermer les centaines de mosquées
salafistes qui se trouvent en france
c'est pour ça que nous ne parvenons pas
à empêcher les gens de rentrer sur notre
sol
en réalité ce n'est pas que ces gens-là
sont surpuissants c'est que nous sommes
impuissants nous sommes impuissants à
cause de cet état de droit que toute la
classe politique vénère donc la question
ce n'est pas est-ce qu'on sort de l'état
de droit comme les mauvaises langues
aujourd'hui perverti pas une conscience
socialiste le laisse croire ou libérale
d'ailleurs le laisse croire
la vraie question c'est comment est ce
qu'on fait évoluer notre état de droit
faut bien comprendre que l'état de droit
est simplement le respect de la
hiérarchie des normes d'une constitution
et puis d'un d'un droit commun d'une
d'une organisation juridique sur
laquelle on s'appuie pour légiférer et
pour agir changer l'état de droit ça ne
suppose pas de le balayer est ce que tu
vois simplement de l'adapter aujourd'hui
notre état de droit n'est plus adapté à
cette législation guerre c'est ça qu'il
faut faire aujourd'hui faire en sorte
que la france puisse massivement
massivement expulsés
les personnes qui menacent son intégrité
et
empêchés de rentrer celle qui
aujourd'hui massivement veulent rentrer
la seule question qui se pose à cette
étape
c est ce que emmanuel macron est capable
d'envisager une telle transformation en
tant que politologue
je pense que la réponse est négative et
que c'est pour ça que les français sont
inquiets
il faut aujourd'hui que le président de
la république change de logiciel libéral
et comprennent que la menace à laquelle
la france est confrontée nécessite de
sortir du logiciel social libéral qui a
le sien à vous entendre il est question
donc d'une certaine mentalité en france
est ce que vous ne faites pas et quoi
aussi aux propos du ministre de
l'éducation jean michel bancaire
lui-même qui évoquait dans la foulée
d'une main de samuel potier qui pointait
du doigt en tout cas la responsabilité
de ce qu'il nomme l'islamo gauchisme en
france absolument et 7 islamo gauchistes
ne vous aura pas échappé qu'il l'a
pointé du doigt sur un socle très
particulier qui est le socle
universitaire celui de la recherche
celui des intellectuels celui qui
consiste à penser les formes de la
société donc on a aujourd'hui une vraie
crise qui traverse notre pays et qui
rappelle la crise des gilet jaune que
vous avez bien connu où on avait une
défiance extrême vis-à-vis des élites à
la fois des élites politiques mais aussi
des élites médiatiques
cet islam au gauchisme le fait qu'ils
soient fortement ancrée dans
l'université ce n'est pas anodin comme
phénomène parce qu'aujourd'hui quand
vous avez des livres qui se publie en
france et qui débarque dans les
librairies d'ailleurs juste en face de
la cathédrale notre dame
ces livres là aujourd'hui sont produits
par ces intellectuels là ils diffusent
cette pensée là dans là et c'est comme
ça que pendant des décennies en france
on a continué d'expliquer à toute la
population qui était de plus en plus
inquiètes en disant mais c'est pas
normal que dans nos quartiers
les commerces deviennent ethnique ce
n'est pas normal que les voiles se
multiplient ce n'est pas normal qu'on se
fasse agresser parce qu'on a un
décolleté ce n'est pas normal qu'on nous
refuse l'entrée
un bus parce que on a une jupe c'est pas
normal qu'on ne puisse pas serrer la
main d'une femme quand on est un homme
ce n'est pas normal qu'on nous demande
du halal à la cantine ou des horaires
séparés dans les piscines et c'est pas
normal qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
personnes qui se fasse poignarder que
dans certains quartiers on ne puisse
plus entrer les français qui tenait ce
discours jusqu'à aujourd'hui été
stigmatisé par qui par cette élite
intellectuelle islamo gauchistes qui a
pris position partout dans l'université
et qui domine aujourd'hui la pensée sur
renarde et tout un tas d'autres et qui
consiste à expliquer à tous ceux qui ne
pensent pas comme eux qu'ils pensent mal
et a tenté de le démontrer par le menu
on a vraiment besoin aujourd'hui à la
fois d'un réveil médiatique d'un réveil
politique mais aussi d'un réveil
intellectuelle c'est à dire d'une
transformation de la logique
intellectuelle dénoncé cet islam au
gauchisme et rétablir une pensée qui est
finalement marginalisés qu'on a appelée
celle de la droite
hors les murs et qui a besoin de revenir
dans la cité parce que c'est la seule
aujourd'hui apporter des réponses